welcome back to leader Johnson show not
just to the listeners and viewers but
again to my good friend from the
worldwide leader in sports who is the
host of college gameday and the host of
tonight's national championship coverage
between Clemson and LSU on ESPN from the
Superdome what a huge game can't wait
for it and I can't wait to hear this
man's hosting because he's great at it
Reese Davis back here on the Rich Eisen
show hello Reese I cannot first of all
you gotta set the the the stage for me
what is it like strolling around that
awesome town with LSU playing in a
national championship game in the
Superdome what has it been like last 48
hours I think it's just been really
intense everywhere you go I mean they're
so hungry for this championship but I
think a lot of it has to do with the
frustration that LSU has had since the
last time they were in a championship
game also played here and you know they
got shutout then didn't cross the
50-yard line until the waning moments of
the game and it sort of cut the soul out
of the program I think and so to have
this resurgence and to have Joe Pearl
have the years that he's had has really
elevated the intensity I sort of laughed
because when the Clemson fans walk up
the LSU fans you know sort of I then
what they're coming to take something
from them but it's been it's been
friendly so far we'll see how it is when
we get closer to kickoff well I mean I
guess that's Davos point all year long
talking about how they are the most
overlooked undefeated national champion
defending its crown maybe in the history
of that ever happening that LSU is
coming to take something from Clemson
technically tonight right yes absolutely
and you know I chuckle at that because
you know I love dabble but you know
anything to keep them as the underdog
it's been sort of silly I think the
reason they've been overlooked is not
their fault at all I agree with that
he's down there are many good teams in
it but Clemson is as good if not better
than everyone you know that doesn't
diminish them it just means that you
know you can't get too excited about
them save the North Carolina game when
they're up 28 nothing with ten minutes
left in the second quarter you know it's
uh you know they have it
had that type of stage until the Fiesta
Bowl and certainly show their toughness
there and then they'll have it again
tonight you know to Clemson's point rich
I mean they would just be the fourth
program in the history of the sport to
win three championships in four years
and to do it in you know in this era is
it would be a little bit different I
mean Alabama's done it in this era
Nebraska sort of on the cusp of it in
the nineties and the other one you have
to go back to Notre Dame in the 47th
there they're already a dynasty but
they're sort of going into that ultra
ethereal realm if there's any such thing
about dynasty right now obviously they
would have done it with two different
quarterbacks one who we just saw have a
24 nothing lead in a divisional NFL
playoff game on Sunday in deshaun Watson
and now here's Trevor Lawrence and
that's the thing that I'm particularly
excited about tonight race is I think
you could make the case easily and write
it in sharpie that the next two first
overall picks of the NFL Draft are
playing against each other in the
Superdome the home of Drew Brees tonight
Reese when you agree absolutely
I'm quarterbacks is such a valued
commodity I'm sure you can make the case
this year the chase young you know hard
to pass him up as the number one overall
pick but I mean burrow has made such
unbelievable improvements and there's
just he's got that you know I hate to
use it because it sounds like such a
sportscaster thing to say but there's
that it factor to it I mean rich with
the advanced metrics this guy's been on
target not you know his completion
percentage is going to set a record for
in something catastrophic tonight but
it's on target percentage he's like in
87 88 percent on target from every throw
this year that's that's unheard of and
you know he's deserving of being the
number one pick and I think that he will
be and there's no question crevel
Hornets would have been the number one
pick last year this year end next year
so I can't fathom a situation in which
he wouldn't go number one overall yeah I
mean and we just showed some video of
Trevor Lawrence running through and past
Ohio State players and that comeback
went and the Fiesta Bowl and I tweeted
out on the spot I think half the NFL is
tanking the 2020 season after seeing out
one run I mean it really is amazing that
said borrow is the hot quarterback
is obviously your Heisman Trophy winner
and that is the key tonight Greece is is
how Clemson handles borrow or do you've
got another one for me here no I think I
think that's it for sure I mean there
are a couple of theories I thought Kevin
Steele the Auburn defensive coordinator
and what they gave up five hundred yards
but they did a good job against him in
the red zone and their whole deal was he
you're not going to fool him he knows
where to go the key is can you make the
window so tight or the coverage so tight
that he squeezes the ball and can't go
where he knows he should be able to and
create that type of disruption Auburn
did a pretty good job with that actually
Mississippi State of all teams held him
to fewer yards than anyone else no one
else has really done anything with them
clemson needs to get a little bit better
pass rush than they have they're not
going to get a bunch of sacks but when
they do get sacs attack opportunities
they got to finish teams haven't done
that against him he's been hit 62 times
in the pocket this year and only sacked
I believe 16 times that's a bunch of
number number number that's really good
yeah and they're not all clean shot hits
but just his ability to navigate the
pocket avoid a little contact create a
little more time and make plays and then
sometimes take off running and get 20
and you know move the sixties good
athlete to Clemson has to limit that
type of stuff and I think Caleb on chase
Dodger is also a good draft prospect is
a real key guy for LSU tonight on the
other side of the ball in terms of
trying to control the Trevor Lawrence
run game you were talking yeah I mean
Joe the Joe burrow NFL stuff that I see
from him is that small little shoulders
shake in the pocket yep to avoid the
sack or to buy the time and when he is
running out of the pocket Reese he's
always got his head up he's not
immediately thinking I'm gonna get the
first down with my feet here because
that's all I've got he's always looking
down the field plays never over because
of that it's unbelievable what he has
turned into in just about a year
unbelief rich I was talking to a scout
or the other day and I actually felt
pretty good about it because I was
thinking boy I really missed on this guy
because last year and when I saw him at
Ohio State you know I thought
good solid college quarterback son of a
coach tough guy good guy to having the
program good guy to lead you're changing
all that stuff but I don't think you
know you completed 57% of his passes
last year wasn't you know it was just
okay and you know and to see what he's
turned into has been remarkable in this
the Scout says to me he goes I've never
in my career for 20 years given a guy
great one year given a guy great dog and
then had to come back and so completely
elevate my very fair evaluation of him
he said I haven't had it happen so I
think a lot of the credit certainly is
due to the offensive scheme and Joe
Brady but most of it is due to Joe
borough I think he's made some
improvements in his mechanics and
throwing motion I think he worked with
Tom Houston noted you know throwing
mechanics guide the former baseball
pitcher he's done all the things he's
needed to do to enhance the other
qualities he already had and he's turned
into just the sensational players that
things can be a great player in the pros
few more minutes left with rece Davis
prior to him hosting tonight's and if a
national championship game on on ESPN
normally and we're gonna be doing this
in the Superbowl into two weeks is a
legacy question who needs it more for
their legacy right who needs this
championship more for their legacy and
in the terms of the coaches obviously
dabble you pointed out he's one two and
three years three and four years would
obviously put him in a different plane
or a different level but coach oh I
think we don't it's not even a question
as to as to who would if you will need
it more right tonight right I mean
nothing is going to change Clemson's not
going to be a lesser program when he's
neither is LSU but Ella Hughes had such
a drought there have been such questions
about edy that he's answered this year
in emphatic style but finishing it would
elevate them in a different way
you know Clemson is already there and
Clemson is going to be back for the
foreseeable future
I assume LSU will be too but I think
this would be a hurtful one to not be
able to finish it not be able to finish
it for LSU tonight
you know look there's a possibility of
that for sure because I mean Clemson's
excellent but I would agree with you I
think in terms of
the greater gain LSU certainly has far
more to gain in terms of that type of
thing regard for the program
championship realm all of that type of
stuff that we like to talk about right
in terms of being rewarded for the
decisions that he's made coach oh and
bringing in Joe Brady and then
delegating the way that he has and
creating an environment in the in the
program that he has with his own
go Tigers sort of stamp it really would
mean so very much for that w in front of
the home folks if you will tonight
they talk all the time about the the
great state of Louisiana at the Heisman
dinner gala set by the governor of
Louisiana John bel Edwards who I asked
him I said now are you a politician type
fan are you a fan fan and he said I'll
tell you two quick stories
he said one he said I was fighting for
re-election I wasn't going to go to the
Texas game he said until I got
challenged by the governor of Texas in a
bed and I was like no well sorry just
got to go to the game and support the
tiger and and the other one he said at
the SEC Championship game he was getting
a little rowdy in his suite and the
Georgia fan next to him started kind of
giving it back to him stood his ground
and then realized it was former Georgia
and Saints defensive lineman Charles
Grant but he was good all the way from
the top elected official in the state
all the way down to the to the good
folks on the Bayou who root for the
Tigers heart soul every day there's a
lot riding on it for the people in the
great state of Louisiana can't wait for
tonight alright so what time's it start
who you with what do you got for me
tonight well you know you because the
sponsor obligations you understand all
of that College gave this actually in
the afternoon it's 3:00 to 5:00 Eastern
Time okay our pregame show is called
championship drive that'll be on 6/8
okay light up kickoff okay and who's
with you normal caste characters we also
a Nick Saban Ryan de Jimbo Fisher will
also join us in addition you know Kirk
Dez coach David will be there but yeah
Jesse Palmer and [ __ ] will join me
for game day this afternoon Desmond so
we've got a little bit a little bit
everybody running around do Vilma it's
around McIlroy's here we've got a lot of
great
and and incor so in the heads are there
right we got all set yeah LC will be on
the championship drive show head gear
coming at a just before we go to kickoff
wow that is a cast of thousands that
you'll be right right there is the
ringmaster Reece you're great at it
thanks for the call we'll chat soon okay
rich take care but right back at you
that's rece Davis at rece Davis on
Twitter and Instagram at ESPN underscore
rece Davis on Twitter right here on the
Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app